michael keaton won big at last night's
sag awards for his leading role in
dopesick yes but he nearly missed out on
the honor as he was seen racing to the
stage to accept his award on the way
back from at the bathroom yep
[Music]
are you kidding me
i have stage fright
come on michael
come on
thank you very much sorry quick trick to
the men's room
i mean listen when you gotta go you
gotta go michael spoke backstage just
moments after accepting his award and
shared what exactly happened when he
decided to slip away
i could have sworn i had another 20
minutes i'm bad at this so i thought
well better hit the bathroom
and there it is listen if you think you
have 20 minutes you're like that's
giving yourself plenty of time i just
love that moment with salma hayek
because she's so naturally funny yes i
mean listen you you watch these shows
you know it's scripted comedy but that
is easily one of the funniest moments of
the night her saying she has you know
stage fright everyone's staring at her
so 20 minutes is not long enough i
thought it was long enough categories
coming what if there's what if the doors
jam what if someone didn't fill the
toilet paper roll what if you know you
rip your pants like stay where you are i
know
maybe he knew he was gonna win or he had
like an inkling so he was like very you
know wanted to be perfect and then
anyway it was a good moment great moment
now well michael gave everyone a good
laugh with his bathroom situation his
speech took on a serious tone as he
addressed the subject matter behind
dopesick a personal story for michael as
he lost his nephew to an accidental
overdose back in 2016.
i have a job
where
i can be part of a production like
dopesick
or worth thank you or whatever
that actually
can spawn
thought
conversation
actual change
this is for my nephew michael
and my sister
i lost michael
i like a few micro drugs
and it hurts
oh my goodness it hurts my heart i know
it's just so raw
uh and you know you have to think even
taking on this role in this movie
you know is is
influenced by you know what happened in
his life and losing his nephew like that
wow yeah that's you know but he's right
a movie or a story a series like that
does
spark conversation and does hopefully
spark change so yeah
i just love that he gave a shout out to
his sister as well for sure